and that is downstairs at 97 ball four
so the fastball command very spotty and
bolanos moncada yasmani was over four
years today now the 1-0 delivery and
that smack towards short actually going
to get through into center field for a
base hit montana with a play in front of
him turns second he's on his way to
third standing first and third with two
outs here in the first inning for the
white sox the base hit for grand all
here we go 3-0
way downstairs ball four here comes
monkatta and the sox take the lead
on a wild pitch it's one nothing in the
first i'll be honest with you salvador
perez had no idea what that ball was
going to do he just kind of dropped to
his knees and stayed right there
it was completely off to the side of his
body he never got any piece of that ball
blocked
so it's first and second with two down
and now the left fielder eloy jimenez
now the 1-0 pitch
and that's hit in the air to center
field hit pretty well backing up now is
starling at the track leaps up and
cannot make the catch it went over is
over the wall out of his glove and over
the wall
that is going to be a home run for eloy
jimenez a three run shot and the white
sox put up a four spot here in the first
inning this is a slider that didn't
slide and alloy doesn't get all of it
but he gets enough of it but watch it
again his second home run he's now
driven in five starling is timing it
well it just bounces out of his glove
because that's not out of the park
that's right it literally was almost
like a trampoline effect
and he wants to know where it is well
it's pretty easy it's over the wall hard
to believe after all those years after
drafting this man this is the first time
he's starting a game for the chicago
white sox
there goes the run of the full comp
pitch swung on a miss to throw on down
is going to be in plenty of time
strike him out throw him out double play
and the inning has come to an end here's
robert
first pitch swinging a high fly ball
into deep right center field starling
looking and it's gone over that right
center field wall and louise robert
has hit his second big league home run
and the white sox now leading it five to
nothing
he got a first ball fastball he doesn't
wait around if he gets something he
likes
this happens the last time bolanos threw
he threw 32 pitches and he's thrown 41
today i'm sure they were hoping to get
him to 50 but he's been so
inconsistent with his command when he
has been
in the zone it's been right down in the
middle
now the two oda and kernacion he'll hit
it into the air shallow left center
that's going to drop in for a hit
so here's eloy
elloy sprays the ball to right field
that's a base knock and into third base
it's encarnacion rounding second hard
and getting in there so two on nobody
out then they're loaded so now it's set
up for nick madrigal looking for that
first major league hit
ground ball up to middle modesty touches
second throws to first and they get the
double play nicely done top of the order
now for luis robert
one ball one strike pitch a little
looper into left center field that's
going to get down for a base hit to the
wall
garcia will score
luis robert to second base with a double
he's got a three-hit game he's a triple
shot of the cycle and you're on montana
batting with a man in scoring positions
there's the 1-0 a high chopper off a
home plate sky-high on the infield
newberry with a bare hand throw and he
throws it away robert's going to come
around third he's going to score and the
white sox have added on another run and
leaves seven to nothing bring up eloy
jimenez two and two
that was not a good one and it's bash to
left center field de loy jimenez hits a
hangar all the way to the warning track
and throttles down
with a two out double
which by the way
what does that leave him triple short of
the cycle o'hearn is one for two
that ball ripped down the right field
line and it will get
monday home so the royals on the
scoreboard o'hearn racing to second base
is there with a double and his fourth
rbi of the year so it'll be up to whit
who's two for three on the evening
well struck left field that ball is back
and it is a goner
with merrifield with a two-run home run
and the royals have cut it to 7-3
and that means luis robert gets a fifth
at bat in this game already and he's a
triple away from a cycle
down the left field line into the corner
not enough foul territory though for it
to be a triple you don't think
robert has a double and his very first
four hit game o'hern has two hits in
this game
to the left side and through
this will score the royals fourth run
and how about ryan o'hearn three hits
against southpaw top of the ninth seven
four white sox lead looking for a little
more here and grand all hits one in the
air and a left center field that ball is
going to get down for extra bases
scoring will be montana it's a two run
double for yasmani grandahl two down to
eloy jimenez here is the pitch
and a ground ball to the left side it's
gonna be a base hit it's gonna get a run
home
heading toward third is goings and the
white sox get into double digits thanks
to eloy jimenez first pitch to garcia
line shot back up the middle base hit
center field
here comes goins to score the 11th run
of the game for the white sox they lead
11-4 here in the ninth
that's second and third for bubba
starling
3-2
on the ground third base joanne monkatta
finishes off the first save in cody
hoyer's career
and the sox get a massive performance
from the young stars 11-5 shadow high
fives for everybody